[Music]
that's all let's drink it
it's just cool let's drink it like who's
that as a drop we are going on a journey
together beer is something that you can
get super weird with to try some of the
craziest beers that exist in the craft
brewing movement rate now look at the
color of that one it's an amazing full
color smells a little bit like a mop
you're looking at over 2 million
Scoville that's irresponsible you ready
for this yes I'm excited let's do it
let's do it so today I'm at the yoga
loft in beautiful Manhattan Beach
California to meet up with comedy legend
Bert Kreischer and do a little work on
her inner self as we get to middle age
or metabolism slows down a bit right
that's a bagel yeah if you want to
you've got a long long tradition of
mixing [ __ ] up yes I do
so that's where we're going next [ __ ]
dr. Dre yeah Puff Daddy huh yeah made a
baby yeah a lot of beer purists would
say what we're doing right now is
blasphemy you're about to have a
beautiful dark inky stout made with
weapons-grade capsicum from me and
things are going so well Sam this is a
beer that I brewed with human saliva you
seem so happy about drinking your own
spit man should we finish this probably
good off yet there's six thousand
breweries in America flying the Freak
flags in all different directions
I think the weirder the better this is
an interesting beer you're making me
rethink the things that I had doubts
about yeah it was odd and we did drink
it
cheers Cheers
[Music]